les refuge pour migrants illégaux ou
sans papiers déborde la maison de
l'annonciation en a reçu 225 en deux
jours
daniel ariely cas et leurs trois enfants
ont traversé la frontière dimanche
mais depuis que sa belle soeur a été
assassiné le 3 juin ariely kahn dort
plus le couple mexicain vivait à voir s
il avait le voisine d'el paso
il y a cinq ans il avait fui la ville de
thorium ou arias licka a vu sa mère sa
soeur et sa nièce se faire tuer victimes
de balles perdues lors d'un affrontement
entre gagne on savait dit il qu'on
risquait d'être séparé de nos enfants à
la frontière mais c'est moins grave que
de risquer sa vie en détention seul
pendant 24 heures
daniel accrue ne pas les revoir reuben
garcia a fondé ce refuge il y à 40 ans
parce que les autres refusaient
d'héberger des immigrants illégaux
aujourd'hui il accueille le trop plein
des services d'immigration
ceux qui ne seront pas poursuivis faute
de places dans les centres de détention
et voulait pas mourir pour monsieur
garcia les consommateurs de drogue sont
en partie responsables de la violence
qui force les gens à fuir leur pays
selon lui ce trafic de 50 milliards par
année finances des cartels qui sèment la
terreur et corrompt juges et policiers
maman m'a stoppée
au guatemala marisol étaient harcelés
par les voyous qui avait braqué la
boutique où elle travaillait un jour ils
s'en prennent à sa fille après l'école
et lui fracturé un bras
terrorisée marisol quitte son pays à la
mi mai en laissant sa fille derrière au
soin de sa mère pendant deux semaines
elles affrontent tous les dangers elle
est même prise en otage pendant trois
jours quand elle arrive à la frontière
d'el paso le 10 juin
elle sait qu'on risque de lui enlever
son bébé elle est détenue pendant 24
heures et longuement interrogé pour
savoir si son bébé avait vraiment besoin
de le dire
mais pourquoi at elle pris tant de
risques pour arriver ici pour travailler
dit elle et faire venir ma fille au plus
vite pour que mes enfants est une vie
différente
je veux dit elle qu'il peut savoir
l'enfance que je n'ai pas eu ici sophie
langlois à radio-canada à el paso au
texas